deux maires sur le fond en pleine crise
sanitaire
depuis deux mois d'un art moraine et
nicolas soret font bloc face au virus
mais aussi face à l'état pour le maire
sortant de joigny et son successeur la
réouverture du marché couvert début
avril a été une première victoire
même si cette décision a été difficile à
prendre pour nous ça a été un vrai débat
est de toute façon générale depuis le
début de la crise je pense que c'est le
sentiment de tous les maires de france
de tous les élus locaux c'est il ya une
charge psychologique émotionnel qui est
importante en ce moment parce que vous
vous dites c'est quand même pas tous les
jours que quand on prend une décision on
se dit si je prends la mauvaise décision
c'est peut-être des morts
au bout du chemin mais l approche du
déconfinement la tension monte chez les
élus de plus en plus d'habitants sortent
de chez eux étant déjà de reprendre une
vie normale avec la réouverture des
commerces dès lundi le maire de joigny
promet de redoubler d'efforts pour
éviter une seconde vague
il faut maintenir la pression à former
les gens c'est très important
les accompagner dire que il faut surtout
pas baisser la garde et nous nous les
maires on doit accompagner nos
populations là dessus certains par les
deux premiers de cordée
les maires sont aussi les premiers de
corvée et on a on aura ce travail là les
maires premier de corvée mais aussi
premier responsable auprès de leurs
administrés
pour nicolas soret le déconfinement doit
aussi être l'occasion pour l'état de
faire confiance aux élus locaux
moi je suis plutôt pour qu'on nous
laisse nous évaluer les choses bien sûr
avec un cadre général mais si le cadre
il est trop stricte comme ce qui arrive
avec les écoles avec ce protocole
sanitaire extrêmement chargée en finale
on a presque on a plus de liberté
d'appréciation de plus en plus souvent
mise à l'écart les maires sont revenus
en première ligne après cette crise se
posera la question du rôle exact qu'ils
auront à jouer à l'avenir